Guys, euh donc vidéo aujourd'hui qu'on
va parler des personnalités, apprendre
des types de personnalités et comment ça
peut t'aider dans les sales.
Donc
euh l'influence dans le fond d'abord
comprendre que l'influence c'est
s se sentir compris. Donc quand tu te
sens compris, tu as beaucoup plus
confiance en la personne puis tu as du
plaisir à discuter avec elle parce que
tu te sens compris. Puis c'est ça qu'en
vente est hyper important, c'est de
faire cerne qu'elle est comprise.
C'est là que tu peux avoir une influence
sur cette personnelà. Pas nécessement
une influence négative mais une
influence que tu peux aider la personne
à guider dans la guider vers un choix
qui est positif pour elle. Donc ta
solution par exemple
ta solution business.
Donc avant de commencer là-dessus, je
voulais directement juste présenter les
types de personnalités qu'on va
présenter très rapidement.
Oh ! Je suis pas capable des euh donc
ben le premier ici, vous voyez pas le
titre mais bon c'est empathique. Donc
premier titre c'est empathique. Donc la
qualité il va être très chaleureux, très
sensible aux émotions à oh e tu as vécu
telle à faire ça me touche non puis tu
sais vraiment aux émotions tu vois son
besoin c'est d'être reconnu en tant que
personne vraiment sentir que c'est un
humain puis que il doit sentir queon
porte attention à ses émotions puis tout
ça puis que
donc àc une personne comme ça ça va être
vraiment de parler des émotions, on
parla du du feeling intérieur et cetera
euh par la suite euh pour la partie euh
Non, c'est je peux pas ben écoute va
falloir que je me promène de même. Donc
pour le travail man, donc lui c'est le
comme vraiment une personnalité qui est
bleue. Donc au niveau très logique, très
organisé euh tu peux donner des
chiffres, des stats, des concepts très
précis. Puis lui sa perception c'est par
la pensée donc de comprendre tout ce
qu'il l'entoure. Son besoin c'est être
reconnu pour ses compétences dans sentir
que il sent il sent là que il maîtrise
ce qu'il dit, il maîtrise ce qu'il fait
puis il se sent compétent. Donc pour
faire sentir que cette personnel est en
en bonne main si faire sentir qu'elle
est compétente. Par la suite le
persévérant il va être un observateur
engagé. Donc lui, ça va être ses
opinions qui va être les opinions sont
super importantes. Donc puis à lui à
être reconnu pour ses convictions. Donc
lui, je dirais que je le connais un peu
moins.
Euh
par la suite, le promoteur, il s'adapte
vraiment rapidement, il est dynamique,
il est dans l'action euh l'excitation du
challenge. Puis lui, il va vraiment
passer à l'action rapidement. OK, go, on
le fait, c'est cool. E, passe l'action,
tu sais, ça vite.
Euh, le rebelle, lui, va être spontané,
ludique, très rapide. Donc les
relations, ça va être super important le
plaisir de travailler tout le monde
ensemble. Donc euh le contact liberté,
ça va être vraiment là de qui va aller
le chercher. Fait de parler là full he
let's go puis on on embête dans un
projet puis euh check, ça va tenner du
temps, ça vaer des des possibilités puis
tout ça va être cool. Par la suite, le
rêveur, lui, ça va être vraiment là, on
voit là
macro, tu sais, les possibilités,
l'infini vraiment là
plus ça imaginatif, tu sais, réfléchi.
Fait que lui là, ça va être vraiment
on voit gros, on voit c'est pas juste
qu'on fait aujourd'hui qui compte, c'est
toute l'ampleur tu sais.
Puis lui son besoin c'est le retrait
donc d'être seul puis de pouvoir
réfléchir à tout ça. Donc maintenant
qu'on a vu les six types de
personnalité, on va comprendre un peu le
background de ça puis comment ça peut
être utile dans tes dans tes sales, dans
tes relations interpersonnelles et
cetera.
Donc
c'est ce qui nous mène à l'influence à
gage se sentir compris. Euh
je vaux
bon d'abord tu peux poser la question
toi c'est quoi ton profil puis c'est
quoi le profil de la personne à qui tu
parles puis ça ça vient que le temps.
Moi, je suis vraiment pas le le le best
là-dedans pour catcher c'est quoi la
personnalité de l'autre personne de l'
côté. Je suis vraiment en phase de
d'apprentissage.
Mais je pense c'est de quoi à garder en
tête tout le temps de essayer de attends
là je parle à quelqu'un. C'est quoi son
type de personnalité pour après ça
adapter ton euh
comment toi tu vas agir. Donc faire une
sorte de miroir avec la personne. Si la
personne est en mode imaginatif, ben
d'embarquer en mode imaginatif. Puis là,
tu vas tu vas créer des liens avec la
personne qui elle va se sentir compris,
elle va se sentir bien à parler avec
toi. Donc super important et dans tes
relations interpersonnelles
comme par exemple contre exemple, ça
serait quelqu'un qui est
je sais pas moi full imaginatif puis on
voit puis on réfléchit puis et cetera
puis là la personne est en mode full euh
réfléchi, imaginatif et cetera. Là tu
arrives e go action action go c'est quoi
on fait quoi là là ? Tu sais c'est quoi
là tu crées un contraste qui fait une
friction dans la relation fait que ça
fait que pour l'autre personne c'est pas
plaisant d'être avec toi, de discuter
avec toi parce que tu fais pas un bon
miroir avec elle. Donc ça crée une
friction. Puis l'objectif dans tes
relations, c'est de diminuer au maximum
la friction en faisant un miroir
avec sa personnalité. Puis euh donc au
niveau des euh types de personnalité, il
y a trois couches. Ça là, on va aller
plus rentr au niveau plus profond un
peu, mais il va avoir le masque. Donc la
personne c'est qu'est-ce qu' à montre de
de de elle, c'est quoi ses comportements
de surface et cetera. Par la suite, il
va avir ses blessures à l'intérieur.
Donc c'est quoi qu'elle dirige en
secret, tu sais peut-être c'est son
besoin profond. Donc on va le voir plus
tard. puis le miroir. Donc l'objectif
c'est ça, c'est de parler dans sa langue
pour qu'elle s compris qu'elle sauve
puis potentiellement qu' elle achète tes
services parce que tu as compris son
besoin à sent confiance se sent pas
closer par le vendeur. C'est vraiment
juste e on a une belle discussion je
sens je vois la valeur puis j'ai
confiance que tu vas livrer la valeur.
Donc ça ça se passe au niveau du miroir.
Donc là, on s'en va au niveau des
personnalités puis les types de
blessures qu'ils ont. Fait lui qui est
dominant, il va prendre l'action tout le
temps puis tout le temps let's go let's
go. Mais lui sa blessure ça va être la
trahison son masque ça va être le
contrôle de tout ce qui l'entoure.
Donc lui c'est par exemple c'est c'est
toi qui a les cartes en main, tu
décides. Donc quand tu es à quelqu'un
comme ça, c'est ça que cette personnelà
attend. Donc puis pourquoi ça marche ?
Parce que ben non, c'est pourquoi ça
marche. Sois ferme, donne-lui des
options et laisse-le choisir.
Il respecte ceux qui ne se qui ne plient
pas. Il a besoin de gagner. Donc
plie-toi pas à lui mais propose des des
options directes puis il va aimer ça de
OK, on passe l'action mais on a des
options directes puis
il veut quand même décider par contre tu
sais fait adapter en fonction de lui.
Par la suite, lui qui était social, qui
était full e let's go mais lui il a une
blessure qui était du rejet sement c'est
le charme. Donc de plaire à tout le
monde
puis lui c'est dire e j'adore ton
énergie on avance ensemble c'est cool un
bon vibe donc parler de lui tu sais
valider ses idées avant de pitcher ça
j'aime ça ce que tu as dit c'est
vraiment nice. Donc parler de personne
pas de système vraiment les humains.
sais les histoires humaines, ça ça le
touche parce que lui justement il y a eu
du rejet fait que de sentir validé un
peu ben ça va lui faire du bien. Par la
suite, lui qui est analytique sa
blessure ça a été l'injustice.
Donc dans sa vie peut-être pu là juste
on revient rapidement là quand on parle
de blessures, c'est des blessures qu' eu
peut-être dans la petite enfance qui
était jeune puis qu'il suit encore
aujourd'hui.
Donc là par exemple, est-ce que
l'injustice que l'analytique a eu ? Puis
là, il va aller faire un masque et de la
rigueur. Donc vous comprenez, il y a eu
de l'injustice qui était jeune. Puis là,
il va aller compl il va aller régler ça
avec de la rigueur de des chiffres, des
stats de pourquoi on fait ça de même,
pourquoi c pourquoi ça pour que ça soit
juste.
Donc lui c'est tu par analysons les
faits pour que ce soit parfaitement
juste. plus c'est ça c'est soit précis
soit juste puis a pas excusez-moi qu' a
pas d'injustice
donc il veut la structure des données
des faits vérifiables laisse du silence
il traite en interne donc ça lui il
laisse le temps de de vérifier vraiment
les faits de vérifier tout ça puis il
dit un seul mensonge mensonge et il est
perdu pour toujours. Donc lui là si tu
mets sur des faits ou peu importe tu le
prends parce que lui on se rappelle que
il y a eu de l'injustice puis lui c'est
la rigueur qui va qui va lui faire du
bien qui va aller combler cette blessure
là d'injustice.
Le loyal donc lui sa blessure ça a été
l'abandon. Il s'est senti abandonné
jeune. Son m ça va être la fiabilité
pour que tout le monde soit s qu' est
fiable.
Donc lui là dit je m'engage à être là à
chaque étape, il va vraiment aimer ça
pour parce que justement il s déjà senti
abandonné qui était jeune. Donc là il
dit je vais être là pour chaque étape,
on va on va travailler ensemble
inquiète-toi pas les KPI on va les
atteindre, on a eu un background, on va
on va y arriver puis lui il va aimer ça.
Donc rassurer sur la durée et on va être
là même dans 2 mois, on va être là
encore travailler ensemble dans 1 an on
va continuer à faire qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire pour te suivre donc il veut des
témoignages de clients qui sont
satisfaits des suivis post vent puis on
a pas une nouvelle qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé et cetera
comment ça va dat puis ça va être
cohérent du début jusqu'à la fin donc
toujours être en mode
poser des questions pour comprendre sa
réalité puis
l'accompagner
Puis lui par contre si tu as une
promesse qui est non tenue, tu brises la
relation directement, c'est sans retour.
Et lui qui est plus visionnaire, lui
qu'on disait que tuit imaginatif, donc
lui çait la blessure ça a été de
l'humiliation. Il s'est censé humilié
puis là il va aller porter un masque de
vision de visionnaire.
Donc
lui dire ta vision va propulser ton
business au niveau supérieur. Donc
ça là, qu'est-ce qu'on on travaille le
service, le produit que qu'on qu'on que
je vous propose, ça va vraiment changer
tout pour votre business. Ça va
augmenter vos s peu importe mais
vraiment là ça va apporter votre
business ici mais ça va l'apporter à un
autre level, vous comprenez ? vraiment
mettre l'ense-dessus de la vision où
c'est qu'on s'en va avec ça. vend le
rêve d'abord puis après ça la structure
ça s'en vient mais faut il lui vendre le
rêve où c'est qu'on s'en va tu sais puis
puis le corrige le pas en public jamais
sur aucun prétexte parce que lui on se
rappelle c'était il y a eu de
l'humiliation fait aucune humiliation
pour lui mais c'est bon c'est de la
logique pour tout le monde mais vous
comprenez
euh lui qui est caméléon c'est lui qui
va qu'on disait qui va s'adapter à tout
le monde pour plaire à tout le monde.
lui saure ça de l'identité donc
il s'est pas senti aimé comme il était
donc son masque qui va mettre ça il va
être adaptable il va s'adapter à tout le
monde parce qu'il sent pas aimer comme
qu'il est
puis lui dire on va créer une solution
qui te ressemble ça va être adapté à tes
besoins. vraiment lui faire comprendre
que tu es important toi là ce que tu as
besoin c'est important donc on dit pas
ça c'est là pour lui on sort du script
préfet là puis on va matcher son énergie
en mode on va reformuler tes tes mots on
va expliciter tes besoin tes peurs e
même tu me dis tu as même pas dit tes
peurs puis je vais même nommer je vais
dire je comprends que il y a ça que tu
as peur que telle arrive telle chose qui
arrive puis là lui il va se sentir
compris tu sais Puis il dit
son oui peut-être du social. Vérifie
l'engagement réel. Peut-être qu'il va se
plier à toi en disant oui parce que il
veut
il veut se faire aimer.
Donc là il va s'adapter
mais là vraiment vérifier parce que lui
il y en a peut-être qui vont justement
se plier rapidement. C'est du monde vont
peut-être acheter rapidement parce que
s'il sentent la pression. OK, c'est bon,
let's go. On embarque. Donc, on fait pas
de la vente à pression, c'est mieux de
vérifier l'engagement réel. Est-ce que
il y a vraiment un besoin pour eux ?
Puis la personne qui se sent comprise
achète,
pas celle à qui on veut. Donc, moi une
phrase qui m'est restée, je m c'est qui
m'avait cité ça, mais il y a personne
qui qui veut se faire vendre de quoi ?
Tout le monde veut se faire comprendre
puis tout le monde veut voir qui se fait
comprendre.
Donc
fais en sorte que la personne en face de
toi se sente comprise.
Puis la meilleure outil pour ça, c'est
le miroir.
C'est pas de la manipulation, c'est de
l'empathie stratégique. Donc vraiment on
met pas ça en mode c'est de la
manipulation,
c'est en mode je vais ressentir ce que
tu ressens pour mieux te guider vers tes
objectifs pour voir si je peux t'aider
puis vraiment garder en mode
bienveillant.
Ouais, c'est ça. C'est purement
bienveillant au final. C'est qu'il y en
a qui vont être sa défensive quand c'est
ils vont sentir qu'il se font vendre de
quoi.
Donc
trois actions concrètes que tu peux
commencer dès maintenant, c'est
identifier le type en amont. Donc ben
d'abord peut-être identifier toi c'est
quoi ton ton type de personnalité.
peut-être identifier les types de
personnalités que
tu es plus proche de qui sont plus
facile pour toi de de de d'agir comme
eux en miroir.
Puis potentiellement par la suite si tu
sais que tu vas rencontrer une personne
peu importe peut-être d'aller voir un
peu analyser OK quel type de personne
j'ai face à moi puis d'essayer d'activer
le plus rapidement possible dans les
rencontres le miroir. Donc peut-être
dans les deux premières minutes essayer
de catcher OK quel type de personne que
tuas en avant de toi puis de commencer à
faire le miroir puis
c'est ça. Donc parle à son besoin
profond, pas à ses objections logiques.
Donc essaie de comprendre la personne
que tu es en face de toi, ses blesseurs
qu'il a vécu pour vraiment venir le
rassurer
en fonction de ces blessures qu'il y a.
Donc c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup
d'informations, c'est complexe quand
même,
mais si tu réussis à tout comprendre ça,
donc son type de personnalité, ses
besoins, son masque, ses blessures,
tu es capable vraiment de créer des
liens très forts avec les personnes
purement humain puis tu peux vraiment
les guider de manière bienveillante
pour les aider.
Donc
quel profil te donne le plus de filet ?
une question que tu peux te poser. Donc
passe une excellente fin de journée.